[Music]
I realized that devops and cloud
computing were emerging fluid and I got
interested in them after some research I
decided to pursue the postgraduate
program in devops with help of Simply
learn with Caltech ctm after completion
of course I cracked a job with a hike of
100 and I'm very happy with it hey I am
Deepak tiwari my hometown is sasaram
Bihar so I joined to the new as a cloud
engineer I was able to track the job
with the help of skills and knowledge I
learned from siblina I graduated from IC
College of Engineers greater Noida in
2019 and got a job in TCS as a role of
system engineer but there wasn't any
much scope for cloud and devops in that
job but since I was really interested in
this field and wanted to do the proper
course and gain a proper knowledge in
that field I did some research and
joined whose career program in devops
and simply learns which partnership with
Caltech CTO the post curriculum was
really in depth and the character name
was something that attracted me all the
instructor were very good and
experienced and also one feature which
is Virtual Lab which helped me a lot in
exercising and doing my work on daily to
daily basis I learned to use different
Tools in Cloud as well as devops such as
easy to instance ECS container
technology such as Docker kubernetes it
is really easy to do my daily to daily
task which I learned from Simply learned
and have a confidence in doing my work
on day-to-day applications my long term
goal is to start my own company where I
can give services in Cloud as well as
devops to my clients I want to have
better understanding on the technology
I'm working on right now and also help
my employers and client grow much
upskilling is very important in our
lives because it helps in giving you new
opportunity you may free time I like to
read books play cricket and traveling I
also play video games especially counted
strike whenever I can keep learning keep
investing in yourself and keep up
Skilling foreign